[Music]
[Applause]
what if we could write idiomatic go and
build it and run it in the browser just
like any other go program can we do that
let's find out so today we're going to
learn about web assembly is how to use
web assembly with go show what's
possible today and briefly look at what
will be possible tomorrow so let's start
with web assembly what is web assembly
it's a web standard assembly format it
has had costs browser support since
early 2018 it was originally built for
fast numerical calculations where
JavaScript would get slow it has a
JavaScript interface to access existing
browser API sand perform Dom
manipulation it could eventually replace
JavaScript altogether and wouldn't that
be great so what does this have to do
with go so let's take a small detour
first girlfriend GS is a project that
has allowed going the browser's since
early 2015 it's a tool built for
compiling go to JavaScript it was
written by a guy called Richard Musial
it supports most of the standard library
and there are many community bindings
for existing web technologies such as
WebSockets local storage and others it's
it's very easy to use you install go for
GS and then you just used to go for J's
command line just like you with the co
command line you compile main package
and it spits out the main lodge ass and
you can load that in your HTML file so
can we use go with web assembly instead
yes
so go 111 shipped with the experimental
support for web assembly experimental
support means that it doesn't have the
same backwards compatibility guarantees
as other parts of the standard library
so you can expect your code to not
necessarily compile cleanly when you
upgrade your versions it was also
implemented by Richard Musial that was
funny because there was like an open
issue about implementing web assembly
started by Brad Fitzpatrick and
lots of discussion about how to do this
and then one day Richard mutual popped
up and said I've started implementing
this there's everyone's like yes finally
so it supports most of the standard
library including net HTTP or client
requests which we're going to see a
little bit more about later the current
implementation is focused primarily on
running in the browser and as we'll see
another consequence is that it produces
quite large files and that's partly
because webassembly still very early in
its development partly because of the
heavy go around time and difficulties of
implementing dead code elimination in
the face of runtime reflection this is
huge numbers of blocks have been written
on this subject essentially it's a
complicated problem but so if you
contrast that to the go for GS compile
instruction that we just looked at it's
now built into the go built runtime the
go compiler mm-hm and you just set the
go OS to Jas go arch to wasn't and you
run go build spits out the Watson file
and we'll see shortly just how you use
it but we're also going to take a quick
look at an another go compiler project
that supports web assembly you may or
may not have heard of tiny go before it
was created by IKEA on Latin primarily
for using go on microcontrollers and it
turns out that when you try to create a
compiler that can pass go from
microcontrollers you also end up trying
to solve the same problems that you
would want to solve in a web environment
so TinyCo produces tiny binaries it's
built on the LLVM stack and some guy
came along and open an issue on the tiny
go repository and said hey could we do
small assembly for this and nykeya was
like yes and so he kind of implemented
the the stuff for it and someone made a
hello world example and it turned out to
be like tons smaller than the standard
library implementation and this is not a
criticism of the standard library
implementation because
plain ego does not even have a garbage
collector at this point it's like a very
early stages super interesting project a
completely different direction from the
main compiler but very exciting to keep
an eye on we're gonna see some examples
of that later on so enough talking about
that how do we use web assembly we'd go
so the first thing you'll need to do is
copy the necessary files from the go
root directory in order to execute web
assembly you will need to have some
JavaScript shims and in this case a
minimal HTML file that kind of load
stuff ever sembly into the browser and
execute it actually just puts a button
on there that you can run your web
assembly with so you also need to make
sure that you set a correct content type
I have included a small snippet here of
just HTTP handler that kind of intercept
any wasn't files and set the content
type because no browser is going to load
the Watson file correctly unless the
content type is set in the response so
enough theory let's let's take it for a
spin and I've got a couple of examples
we're going to take a look at here let's
see okay so this is a check out of a
repository that I've created called
Wesen experiments you'll find a link to
the github repository in a later slide
but for now let's just take a look at
the first file on the show here so we've
got a hello world example a simple kind
of just import from it's print hello
world and you'll notice that this
includes ajs Watson build tag now this
is just here to ensure that we only ever
build this when we're specifying the
correct environment variables you don't
need to include this but it's just kind
of sanity and so let's run like hello
and so as you can see this runs the go
build command that we talked about
before SS they are the incorrect
environment variables and spits it out
into the HTM
directory it also copies the files from
the go route depending on your current
go binary so this is a forward
compatible a thing to note is that you
need to make sure that you are running
the same awesome exact rjs as the
version of go that you were using to
build your web assembly file this is
very important and if you run something
like this you'll ensure that always
happens so this has been sped out into
the HTML directory and then what we've
got is a little go file that just serves
the may not go so that's serving on
localhost
let's take a look yet and I want to open
the network tab here so you can see just
the size of the web assembly file when
we're loading it so the file that we've
generated here is two point forty four
megabytes and if you haven't used by the
sudden before you'll be like whoa that's
huge he's going on but as I said that
it's a complicated issue essentially and
small improvements are already been made
to the standard library to shrink that
size a little bit but we'll talk a
little bit more later about what could
possibly be done to reduce that but
anyway now that we're here we've loaded
it let's press run and we got hello
world its first time oh right okay
that's not that interesting let's let's
take a look at something a little bit
more interesting so actually sorry let's
go back for a second that was two point
four or four megabytes now I mentioned
that tiny go comes tiny go produces tiny
line just by comparison so let's let's
try and compile this with tiny go so the
make file I have here pulls the docker
container to use tiny go and basically
there's all the same thing tango has its
own masa Mike suggests you must make
sure to use we're using the same also
makes extra HTML otherwise and if we
serve that up and let's take a look at
the network champion or you reload the
page
we've now got wasn't file that is 62
kilobytes large and that is I think
probably acceptable for most consumers
and sorry let's switch to the console
first if we run that again it produces
hello world so this is great finally
goes very exciting unfortunately none of
the other examples that I'm going to
show you today really work in tango
because it still has a lot of ground to
cover and also at the same time
obviously the standard library is going
to go in the other direction so you can
kind of pick and choose tango or the
standard library and you'll probably
want to choose a standard library more
time but anyway let's move on to the
next example I mentioned earlier that
there is a JavaScript interface for
working with JavaScript values and the
document object module in web assembly
and it's accessed through this import
syscall /j s and what you do essentially
is you'll get a handle on the document
now if you're a JavaScript developer you
look at this and be like this is totally
bastardized JavaScript inside go and
it's true but what this allows us to do
is have this JavaScript interface which
allows us to do things like create
element and get element and then wrap
them in kind of typesafe go wrappers
this kind of thing already happened for
go for J's back in the day and indeed
the Gophers yes packages are almost
immediately transferable to webassembly
Co there's already a huge amount of
stuff that works just out of the box in
webassembly
for example Dom manipulation but I
wanted to show you what it looks like so
what this does here is it looks up a div
or it looks up an element by name target
it will create a new div set the text of
the div and then append the new div to
the target and in order to do that we
will see yes we will insert a little set
here at the end of our build which
inserts a target of just underneath the
Run button so that is what we will
attach to
okay let's reload the page let's press
run and Ella world's exciting excellent
we've got some JavaScript Dom
manipulation right inside our web
assembly file okay again kind of basic
not that interesting now I mentioned
before that we can work directly with
HTTP client requests inside web assembly
and the way that this works is if you're
interested interested in the kind of
deeper details the HTTP client though
the HTTP transport default transport
implements a fetch API based transport
to automatically translate the net HTTP
client requests to fetch API calls in
the browser and all you have to do as a
user is use go HB client as normal so
indeed this if you looked at it looks
just like normal girl code you could
write this in a command line app just
making a request post request to http in
the org sending some content reading it
back out and printing it and to make
things a little bit more interesting
what I've implemented just above here is
a IO writer that writes two divs inside
the document so we're gonna see the
output of this not in the console but
right on the web page so that's made and
this looks exactly the same
we've got a target 'iv just so that we
can I cook onto something where we're
adding the child nodes and and so what
this is gonna do is just send their web
request we're gonna get the response and
just print the response of our button to
the screen okay so exciting right this
is you you saw what it looks like right
it was pure go just using the HTTP new
request client and we've got the JSON
response back from the HDD bin
very cool and so let's take a little bit
deeper and see just how far this rabbit
hole goes what I've got here is a
separate repository which forth the GOP
psycho library and implemented a custom
transport
in G oppressive web on top of the
existing web assembly httpclient
so this back end here what we're looking
at is just a vanilla G OPC server
implementation its implements two
methods get user which is a unary method
which can return an error and get users
which is a stream and the front end if
we look at this it's got some go
generate stuff to you know do the
copying of Vasan exactly and the
inserting of the talkative and all that
the stuff that we had in the make file
before it's got our nice IO writer that
prints to a div but otherwise this looks
just like a gif you see find and you
dialed nothing because you just connect
into yourself the local host and
otherwise this everything below that
line essentially looks exactly like what
you would expect the normal G obviously
trying to look like so we've gotta move
back in client we're doing some requests
here skim over the details essentially
the first one is gonna succeed the
second one's gonna fail I want to print
the error here and then what we've got
is a stream and streaming is always
exciting so let's see if if this works
so this runs proto c runs go generate on
the front end which copies all the files
outputs it to HTML directory we run
Dmitrich ralliers excellent assets
generates thing to compile the static
access into a go file and then we run go
run main let go and so i think you might
be curious just how large this is so I'm
gonna this is a 15.6 megabyte large file
but that's okay because we're totally
compiling the entire G RPC server stack
including the HTTP stack into the the
binary so don't worry about everything
is a-ok so you saw the client what it
does is it will call first bacon recall
which we succeed secondly it will make a
unary call we should fail and then it
should make a service streaming call
that we should seek
slowly print onto the screen okay thank
you and that was those were the examples
so let's let's take a step back and and
look at what the future of web assembly
will look like obviously where were some
days only what I say early 2018 we're
just on a version one things that have
already landed in respect sorry things
are planned to be implemented in all
browsers is threading
I think the Chrome Beta channel already
supports threading in webassembly go
doesn't support it yet as far as I know
but we can look forward to things like
the auto-generated Dom bindings from the
web IDL spec for the Dom go where some
frameworks vector is a popular framework
for go for GS it already runs with
webassembly produces huge files native
browser API so you don't have to go
through the JavaScript bridge that I
showed you in order to many play the Dom
threatening in garbage collection
garbage collection could be one of those
things were okay code doesn't need to
compile in the garbage collector anymore
when it's running in web assembly mode
maybe that could help reduce file size
just continual improvements to the web
assembly spec and implementations and
maybe most exciting of all something I
haven't really touched upon here is that
whoever simply could technically run
anywhere where you have like a web
assembly and interpreter people are
writing things like both assembly
interpreters for running on arm or
running in the cloud and it could be
better than like Java but better than
Java you know so except for you know
replacing Java scripts we might also end
up replacing Java which regreat okay so
I mentioned I would include some links
here the links to my was some
experiments repository the gypsy where
was an example some information about
web assembly and the fourth link there
is a blog to future web assembly I
encourage you to join the web site looks
like on
gopher slack and the tiny of your
channels as well and so can we
Ronco in the router yes but not without
caveats yet but the future is very
exciting I hope you will join me
[Applause]
[Music]